wohin fliegt eigentlich samen der fahrer
des ersten serienautos und weltraum ist
es der asteroidengürtel landete auf dem
mars oder würde irgendwann mal auf die
erde stürzen viele von euch hatten sich
das thema auch whatsapp gewünscht und
was ihr euch da wünscht dauer berichte
ich ja gerne oft da gibt es die besten
themenvorschläge von euch wie er meine
nummer endet das erfolgte am ende des
videos herzlich willkommen bei pixum
science fiction und den e on mars
chroniken hat also allen masc noch einen
letzten comics damen vor oder wird er
jetzt ganz unspektakulär durch den
weltraum fliegen bis ans ende der tage
erstmal unspektakulär ist offensichtlich
anders vor allen dingen zusammenhang mit
dieser geschichte absolut untertreibung
mit seinem tesla roadster als test für
den erstflug der felge navy hat uns
allen masc alle so richtig geflecht was
für eine unglaubliche idee und welche
unfassliche bilder das ganze noch
gekrönt von ein wenig pop kultur mit dem
hitlers guide to the galaxy an bord der
musik space oddity von david bowie aus
der stereoanlage und natürlich einem
handtuch im handschuhfach absolut irre
war das aber wohin fliegt dieses
ungewöhnliche raumfahrzeug jetzt
eigentlich von innen musk waren bisher
nur widersprüchliche aussagen zu hören
zu mast zu mast soeben würfel und das
alles scheint nicht zu stimmen
jonathan mcdowell vom harvard
smithsonian center for astrophysics in
cambridge im us-bundesstaat
massachusetts die hat die bisher
bekannten daten analysiert und weiß
jetzt wohin der tester unterwegs ist und
eins ist sicher
daran wird sich nichts mehr ändern der
treibstoffverbrauch der kurs kann nicht
mehr geändert werden
der tesla ist nach seinen berechnungen
in eine elliptische bahn rund um die
sonne eingeschränkt sowie alles was hier
so im sonnensystem durch die gegend
fliegt planeten asteroiden und jegliche
himmelskörper dabei liegt der
sonnenfenster punkt etwas außerhalb der
mars umlaufbahn im frühsommer wird da
man dann den mars orbit erreichen ohne
allerdings in eine umlaufbahn
einzuschränken
am nächsten würde dem mars am 8 oktober
2020 seien allerdings immer noch in
einer entfernung von sieben millionen
kilometern viel zu weit weg um auf dem
mars zu landen
einzuschlagen das wäre auch gar nicht
gewünscht um den mars nicht mit
substanzen von der erde zu verunreinigen
so oder so wird der tesla wahrscheinlich
viele jahrhunderte seine bahnen ziehen
vielleicht irgendwann mal etwas
abgelenkt aber eins ist sicher eine
gefahr stellt er nicht da dafür ist er
viel zu klein wurde auf die erde stürzen
würde er einfach verglühen wir würden
nichts davon mitbekommen auf der south
by southwest konferenz hat muss jetzt
der neue meilensteine verkündet die big
falken rocket soll erste kurze flüge
bereits in der ersten hälfte des
nächsten jahres machen damit wäre das
erste interplanetaren raum schrift der
menschheit absolut im zeitplan
es wird und bleibt also spannend was
wenn er als erstes neues dazu und zu
allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann
endet meine telefonnummer
bei whatsapp also hier geht das dann
erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen
vom neuesten video garantiert ihr könnt
dort direkt über mich in der redaktion
vom krieg so mitmachen und mehr themen
vorschlagen oder an abstimmungen
teilnehmen und mitbestimmen was ihre
klicks um so passiert denn direkte draht
zu mir einfach hier draufklicken und
natürlich nicht das aber mit der genau
mit der glocke vergessen hier geht es
weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken 1000
raketen zum mars ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran